social media question for you I'm just
curious with this one here if Facebook
if YouTube if Twitter if all of these
apps that we use in us were available in
China the last ten years if all of these
social media apps were available to the
public in China the last ten years do
you think the pandemic and coronavirus
would have gone to the point that it is
today
well if they were uncensored like they
are holy ah yeah i think i think that
the communist party would have acted
very differently because they would not
have been able to hide things like they
did i mean there one of the things that
see Jinping has done in the corona virus
epidemic is to impose extraordinary
information controls now they did that
of course when the virus broke out but
they also they had a brief period of
like three or four days of relative
openness from January 22 January 26 and
then they went back to controlling the
narrative again and we know that because
the Communist Party appointed its
leading group on coronavirus under C
Jinping basically what's happened is he
sort of bypassed the bureaucracy and the
Communist Party has set up these groups
on the economy or whatever well they set
up one of the coronavirus and they
announced the roster On January 26 and
there was a night person group of the
group there was only one person was a
public health official and even she I
think her degree was not in public
health though I'm not positive about
that but we do know that it was heavy
with propaganda officials the vice
chairman was Communist Party's chief of
propaganda the chairman of the leading
group was the premier of the country
who's basically a political hack and
there were a lot of propaganda types on
it which showed that see Jennings
priority was not ending the epidemic but
was controlling the narrow and since
that time there have been evidence of
this
ordinary secrecy campaign so they've
just gone back to the old way of doing
things so yeah things would have been a
lot different if there were Twitter and
Facebook and and there was just an open
and free social media but unfortunately
that's not the case I I think if US was
to negotiate now with them and if China
wants to do any kind of trade deals do
you think it'd be a good idea for
President Trump to say you gotta have
Free Press and you have to allow every
single one of our platforms in your
country with no censorship or else being
doing business together yeah I mean that
would be a good thing to do but see
jumping would never agree to that
because he does believe he believes that
he should have absolute control over the
party that the party should have
absolute control over society so he's
never going to agree to that you know
we've got to face one trade deal sian
January 15th I mean who knows whether
China is going to adhere to its
obligations but phase 2 is just not
going to happen
largely because it is they they kicked
the hard issues down the road and see
Jinping is just not going to give up on
them and the issues that that they kick
down the road like state subsidies or a
lot easier for him to deal with and what
you just talked about which is open and
free media that is just completely
antithetical to see Jinping's conception
of the Communist Party
[Music]